do me a favor ladies gentlemen please
welcome louis c.k
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you now I have one guiding
philosophy which is this is that's an
old saying that I renovated for my own
purpose
it goes give it give a man a fish and
you feed him for a day teach a man to
fish and you feed him for a lifetime
leave the dude alone and he'll figure it
out
what are you gonna cook now I uh I want
to show something from one of your shows
I think I happened last season and then
you tell me how I'm supposed to feel
about this all right all right just go
ahead nerd this is from the louis c.k
show
[Music]
honestly
[Applause]
I didn't mean you know
this guy Jimmy Leonard
like like I was on a plane I was going
flying out to Los Angeles recently for a
lot of important stuff and I was in the
and sitting on a aisle seat with two you
know with three seats neck it was like a
very crowded stressful flight and we're
about to take off and this woman gets on
with her baby like this and her husband
and two other just sad looking kids and
she's just walking through the plane
hating people with her baby so upset and
I saw her coming I realized that she's
sitting here and I'm like uh so she
comes up and she says okay here's how
this is gonna work this is all true she
goes you're sitting in the middle I'm
sitting in the aisle because I have a
baby oh and I thought okay and I told
her here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
get off the plane how do you get to be
in big big movies well it's it's like I
don't know they asked me to do it I
don't audition or anything I don't I
don't like to do movies yeah you don't
like to do well I used to I don't like
auditioning I don't like trying to get
that kind of work right and I used to
audition I never got any parts and the
first movie I got well somebody offered
me and we'll be part they offered they
asked me to audition and I said okay and
I didn't show up because I hate doing it
so then they're insulted good yeah right
just don't show up
Oh Joe I think I well we made another
appointment for you and I didn't show up
to that either and then they sent me the
script and said put yourself on film in
your house and send it to us and I said
yes yes I didn't do it do that
and then they called me and said you got
the part so the thing is this is how I
keep mice this is how I always want to
feel about myself
okay good is these two messages the
first one is from my daughter when she
was five five years old and then the
next the next one is from Andrew okay
okay here we go
okay okay okay okay here's the next one
[Laughter]
how are your daughter's tell me about
them they're great
the youngest one just turned nine and
then the older one remains 12 for a few
more months mm-hmm and they're good I
mean this week is testing week head
schools a lot about that yeah so there
did three days of extensive standardized
testing and you what are the
consequences of the standardized testing
well the way I understand it if the
school's kids don't test well they burn
the school down so it's pretty high
pressure a lot of pressure on the kids
yeah Wow and the tests are written by
people that nobody knows who they are
it's very secretive and the questions
are because they prep to prepare for
these tests for a long time a lot of the
year is about the tests teaching for the
tests teaching to the test they call it
because they decided there's a new way
kids should think and we're gonna prove
they're thinking it by having him pass
these tests or we burn the school down
so anyway my kids kind of panic when
they're in these you know which is okay
you know my mother was a math teacher
and she taught me that moment where you
go I don't know what this is when you
panic that means you're about to figure
it out ah
that means you've let go of what you
know and you're about to grab on to a
new thing that's great that you didn't
know yet so I always I'm there for them
in those moments and go come on just
look at the problem and then I look at
the problems and it's like you know bill
has three goldfish he buys two more how
many dogs live in London
[Music]
better notify the fire department that's
right
sorry to get you out of your basement
workshop but thanks thanks for running
right over yeah yeah oh you've carved
out a a wonderful place for yourself in
the world of show business but comes
with a price I mean when you go places
now yeah it's all different isn't it
yeah people recognize me sometimes good
and bad probably yeah though that's the
guy
no sometimes people ask me for pictures
and I don't like doing it
what no why not well I know you're just
supposed to you supposed to go uh well
you know the fans but I just go no I
don't want to do it yeah but once I'd
like so I always try to be nice how I
say no I go oh you know but thank you
you know okay so I was coming out of a
restaurant once and these two women are
staying there they I hear me say thank
you picture picture so I go I don't know
I'm sorry I I just don't like doing that
I hope that's okay and they're like
they're like okay I said what's your
name though and she's like Janet I go hi
Jean and I'm Louie hi hey guys I'm sorry
to thank you and then I walk away and I
see the two women give their camera to
some guy to take their picture yeah
I had a good Dale's hanging out with my
kids today because they're in my house
and so I decided to stop googling myself
and go see if they need something and my
daughter was doing her homework because
this is a very old joke because it's
July who's doing homework but it just
hit me that that's ridiculous but anyway
she was it doesn't have to be today she
was doing homework once and she said to
me she said daddy what six plus six and
I said twelve because that's true and
she said I have to show the work I was
like well draw a picture of me telling
you I don't know what to tell you I have
this conversation with my son who is 10
who is I guess right between the ages or
daughters and it goes like this well
what would you like for breakfast I'm
not hungry
well yeah but let's just say you were
what how about bacon no how about eggs
no pancakes no and so we go through
every imaginable form of consumable
human right yeah none of which interests
the kid and then so now we go back and
we start over and it's clear that he has
decided on his side he's gonna say no to
everything I come up with but yet they
have to eat yes they do boy what do you
do why are you asking him what he wants
I mean you're you're asking homicide
where everything's headed and look I
know why you're asking I get it but the
thing is you're saying if he doesn't
decide what he wants he won't eat I'm
already eight ball that's never gonna be
his oh yeah with your girls you just put
the food in front here is what we're
having is what I don't want that and I
go alright what do you want them
[Music]
now when I started doing stand-up comedy
I went to a place called The Comedy
Store yeah and I love the Comedy Store
because for one thing there is no better
location for a club especially in Los
Angeles than right there on Sunset
Boulevard right looking out at the
beautiful lights of the nighttime and
the sunset the excitement and so forth
and you also work there but you didn't
what is the problem you didn't like it
or you do like it well you have to pass
audition there no matter who you are and
I never really worked there cuz they
wouldn't I didn't get a chance to
audition and then when at one point I'd
been on your show it was a known
comedian and I called and said can I
work the Comedy Store they said you
still got an audition so you have to
come in and and they put you up for a
like they put you up for a few minutes
and you do your act for Mitzi shore who
is the owner she's she started the club
and so Mitzi shore said I came in to
audition and she's sitting in this table
directly across from me and I go on and
there's a light here that indicates they
used to have a light that would flush
any Eddie Cantor's portrait caricature
yeah and it would go on at the end of
five minutes that's right yeah
so when you see Eddie Cantor get
offstage that's right basically so I go
on and I say hi everybody and I start I
don't think I said hi everybody but
[Music]
[Applause]
I said hello and I started a joke and
the light went on immediately and I
thought well I can't they can't really
be it yeah so I keep going and I see
Mitzi and she's going like this
literally she's going like pointing and
doing this oh my goodness and I thought
well I've been doing this like I don't
have been doing it like 20 years I was
like I'm gonna gotta get off stage after
10 seconds No
so I did like 5 minutes the audience
liked me and then I left and my manager
called and she said I hated him it's
terrible so I just I wasn't allowed to
work there so did you you never went
back I know I after a while like you
know I mean on her she's I don't think
she knows who's there all the time now
she's pretty old she's still there but
I'd sneak here and I go I just shot a
comedy special there that's what I'm
talking about I don't think if it I
think if she sees it she's gonna be like
that kid doesn't belong there that's
important because I think human beings
are still evolving and we're all
responsible for that so there's nothing
less than the human evolution at stake
when you act like an idiot and if you
are an idiot you should be selected out
not not by a committee but by lions like
there should be like I saw this woman on
a plane with some on a plane this woman
gets on the plane she has red shorts and
high heels and a little shirt and she's
like you know like I swear if she had
made a sound it would have been like
yeah like she just was
and she's got the bags and they're way
too wide to fit through the aisle so
instead of picking them up or going
sideways she just goes and just walks
away from them I'm just
and there's the flight attendant who has
like rubber shoes just boring working
woman looks at her and she's like
disgusted but she picks up the bags for
her and she follows her on the plane I
realized this woman's gonna have men who
want her and women who hate her helping
her throughout her life she's always
gonna she's gonna do okay even though
she's worthless there should be some
there should be some element where she
could maybe get eaten by a lion here's
the thing about to me about lying is
that I don't think you should do it
but I get it mm-hmm that's how I feel
but I get it right because kids lie
because they're in trouble you know if
you're in trouble as a kid it's too much
as you can't take it yeah yeah kids
don't lie for some weird Machiavellian
you know they're not like you know my
teacher said about you it's interesting
you know they don't they're not trying
to start something it's just somebody
who's like did you take the chocolate
and they're terrified yeah
verify if you're in trouble you don't
care you're growing up you just go oh
sorry right well again
again I've been in trouble and didn't
work I'm not doing a good job raising my
kids I'm trying but my goal is that
they're better than me I need them to be
better people than I am I'm not a good
guy I mean I don't hurt anybody but I
don't help either
like this is the sort of the level if I
see a woman in a skirt I'm not gonna
look up her skirt but if if she gets
sloppy I'm there that's sort of the
level you know tell me this story this
boding story I'm oh I'm fascinated by
this this happened you were just this
summer that's right I got a boat I can't
really afford one but I got one anyway
and so I got a boat now it's going
around lower Manhattan and then up the
east side and you know you have a radio
on all the time that it's an open
channel so the Coast Guard comes on and
they say please be aware it is a there's
a report of a body in the water
south of the Queensboro Bridge which is
where I was and as soon as they said it
I looked down and there was the dude in
the water oh my god yeah so you're like
right in there at the crime that's what
we think crime scene we don't know I
don't know just if just a floating dead
person yeah and I never seen a dead guy
Oh
have you ever seen a dead person well
I've been to various funerals
[Laughter]
but not like this no this is a dead guy
in the wild that's right that's right
that's right this is a freshly dead
person yeah hasn't been all you know he
just must have been creepy huh it was
creepy and weird and I felt embarrassed
for him a little bit and I mean if I was
the only person there so I had to I
called the Coast Guard he said I got
that dead guy he's right here and so
they said please wait there and so I
just floating in the water and there's
this guy's just me and him how did that
make you feel well I you know I I
thought about I was like this was a
person this is a story this is a you
know a life and she's just a floater now
yeah and that's what they call McComb
floater right and I felt sick you know
all kinds of things and I one point I
was like I have my phone but I don't
want this guy in my phone I don't want a
dead guy I don't want to do that so I
think that's a little trite to think if
I what I would want if someone was if I
was dead in the water so he was there so
I just waited then the cops show up and
the police the police and the fire boat
pull up and they go you as your floater
off the bout it's how you find out it's
called a float because they called it a
floater and then I'm sitting there I
realized I have no right to be here I
have no excuse for sitting here watching
this right so I start backing away and I
called them and I said in case and
unless you need me I'm leaving and I
hear the fire say to the police who is
that
[Laughter]
no it's all very unsavory yeah but you
you know you did the right thing for
heaven's sakes you were like yes I mean
I didn't just plow into him and keep
going no I mean I don't know what else I
don't think I helped or hurt yeah did
you ever hear the the after story about
what and how he got this I looked I
googled it and I guess they said that he
jumped off the bridge so this is yeah I
mean this is like I got nobody knows you
know you know sometimes a person dies
everybody gets all excited they talk
about it all year
yeah but this is just some guy who
couldn't do it anymore you should have
gotten a picture of anything ever I
should what's that you together six rum
in the fan we'd have that to look at
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]